when I was nine my dad had recently died
and I'd been struggling with insomnia I
was seeing a therapist at the time and
they tried everything to no avail then
my mum gave me a tip and I've never had
trouble getting to sleep again
I've since come to learn she was
inadvertently recommending a form of
cognitive behavioral therapy here's what
she told me instead of stressing about
getting to sleep simply enjoy that time
use it to think about the day to make up
stories or just relax and enjoy the
freedom that comes from not having to do
anything for what seems like an endless
amount of time if you don't fall asleep
you'll still get lots of benefits simply
from resting true it's not as
restorative as actual sleep especially
from a hypertrophy perspective but it's
better than nothing and it's still
really good so make that the goal and as
soon as you enjoy that I don't want this
moment to end feeling you'll find you're
much more likely to just fall asleep
partly due to the reduced cortisol that
comes from relaxing but partly just
because of that sod's law isn't it you
enjoy your time in bed you fall asleep
good night and bye for now